las calles de Waldorf ahora libres de
Felinos
todas las aventuras al aire libre están
prohibidas para mí mi fluffy el no
entiende Pobrecito pero se acabaron las
salidas en este pequeño pueblo de la
región de bademutenberg los dueños de
gatos como Regina Martina deben confinar
a sus animales por segundo año
consecutivo es para intentar salvar a la
alondrada una pequeña ave al borde de la
extinción en la región la vida ya no es
normal con este encierro vivimos con el
miedo constante de ver al gato salir
corriendo porque no acepta que lo
traigan de vuelta y sabemos que no es
bueno que esté todo el tiempo encerrado
en casa
la idea de otro entierro como el año
pasado es insoportable tengo nudos en el
estómago y no he dormido mucho estos
últimos días es un encarcelamiento
incomprensible para los gatos estos
felinos están orgullosos de merodear
como y cuando quieren Pero la alondra
crestada vive y anida en el suelo por lo
que es particularmente vulnerable las
construcciones también han reducido su
hábitat natural una cerca rodea los
campos donde se vieron Las dos últimas
parejas las medidas de conservación
ordenadas por la oficina Regional de
protección de la naturaleza no son
precisamente populares
por supuesto queremos que la alondra
crestada continúe poblando nuestra
región y nuestro pueblo está haciendo
todo lo posible pero un paso tan
drástico inevitablemente crea disidencia
el primer encierro salvó a ocho
polluelos según las autoridades
regionales razón de más para continuar
hasta 2025 a pesar de las quejas de los
dueños de gatos que están presentando
múltiples demandas
tuvimos que tomar una decisión una
decisión entre el bienestar animal de
los gatos y la conservación de la
especie de Alondra crestada y la
decisión se toma a favor de la
conservación de la especie
el confinamiento de gatos en baldorf se
prolongará hasta finales de agosto los
infractores se enfrentan a multas que
van desde 500 a 50.000 euros por gatos
atrapados en el acto